vàng cho vàiểm chúng hơn đã sát đi trong giai đoạn cách mặt mới chúng ta cần tập trung từ kẹn bá đồ phá chi lợt.
Đó là một đồ phá mạnh mẽ ở vệ thể chế phát triển.
Đấy mạnh phân cấp phân quen túc đẩy đồ phá vui khó công nghệ đồ nửa xang tạo cho nửa số phát triển năng lực sẵn xuất mới,
các buồn hình phương tức sẵn xuất kinh ra in mới.
Thứ hai tập trung trên đổi cơ cấu, nâng cao chức lợt nguyên lực phát triển nguyên lực,
hình đồ cao trong dụng nhất tại lợt nguyên mạnh mẽ công tạo các bộ, hướng khích và bảo vệ các bộ măng lộ sáng tạo,
giám nghĩ giám là giám triển trên nghiệp giám nghĩ xin, vì lấy chục.
Thứ bà là tiếp tục hoàn thiện đông bộ, ở đồ phá mạnh mẽ trong sự dựng kích tấu hạ tần tình tế sau,
tiếp hạ tần rao thông, tần công nghệ hạ tần ngon lợt.
Đông thời, nô lợt từ kẹn, những nhận vụ chủ yêu của sấu trọng tâm.
Một là xây dựng đàn, với thống chiến sĩ trong sách tựng mạnh toàn dạ,
nâng cao măng lực lĩnh đạo và xức khi lâu của đàn.
Hãy xây dựng đông bộ thế chế phát triển trong tâm là thống phóc lợt cơ chế chiến sách.
Thứ bà là phát triển nên kinh tế thì chường bị giống xây chúng đi á, nâng cao hiệu quả khu vực tinh tế
dạ nước phát triển khu vực tinh tế tuy nhiên, sắc lập mua in tăng trưởng mới,
cơ cấu là nâng kinh tế để mạnh công nghiệp ngoả hệ tại hoa.
Thứ tâm trung chiến khai lột phá với khỏa công nghệ lượng mươi xang tạo của chúng đủ số
tạo nền tàng cho phát triển lực lượng sẵn sách sách mấy hiện đại phương tích sẵn sách mấy
hiệu quả. Năm là phát triển như lực con người phát triển phát hoa thống xử trở thành sự mạnh lội sinh
đồng lực tôn lớn cho phát triển nhân, bên vướng của đất lợt.
Sau tăng cường cuo phòng anh linh đối ngoài, xây dựng quân đội nha dân công man dân cách mạnh chính quyết tinh rời hiện đại
mạnh chính quyết tinh rời, đường ngoài, phóng dịnh tâm công với